Hey there, how are you doing today?
In this class, we'll leave glass and translucent effects
to the side, and we'll learn about something completely
new.
We'll be introducing a brand new shading model,
and that is the two-sided foliage,
which is used to texture foliage like trees or grass.
This one is going to be pretty interesting,
so let's get started.
Two-sided foliage is a particular one
because it really focuses on giving to our vegetation
a realistic and consistent feel when it's hit by the light.
Now, whenever we talk about the specifics of a shader
when hit by a light, we really
start referring to the subsurface scattering
of a material, which is also typically
responsible to create the effect of our skin
when it's close to the light.
They know when it gets actually redder,
that's subsurface scattering.
The two-sided foliage shading model
enables us to customize the subsurface scattering
of a surface and set how light transmission is simulated.
We need to be careful, though, because when using Nomen,
there are a couple of things we need to take care of first.
We need to first make sure that the mobility
setting of our vegetation is set to movable,
and therefore contributing to our dynamic lighting.
And also, we'll have another checkbox
to take care of in the Details panel,
where we'll need to make sure Evaluate World Position
Offset is enabled as well.
But I'll show you in just a second how to do that.
Now, as usual, I'll be jumping directly into the engine
and close the slides.
But remember that each step that I will be taking in Unreal
will also be displayed through screenshots and instructions
here in the PowerPoint file that is at your disposal,
so you can easily follow along.
Together with the sample material
that we will check out in just a moment,
you should be able to walk in the right direction
as we draft a new material out.
But this one is going to be pretty simple,
so I don't think you'll have any issues.
Our goal for today is to create a three shader
using the two-sided foliage shading model.
And this three is also going to have
some nice animated leaves.
So let's fire up the engine and see how to achieve that.
All right, we're in the Plant Movement section
of our default map.
And here displayed, we can see two examples of trees
using the two-sided foliage shading model.
Now let's click on the first one
and make sure that the mobility of this mesh
is set to movable.
And then we want to enable the evaluation
of the world position offset
in the ray tracing advanced settings.
So make sure that this checkbox is set to true.
Okay, perhaps the leaves on this tree
might be moving a little bit too fast,
but we'll see in just a moment
that these settings are really easy to adjust
with the correct parameters
exposed to a material instance.
Now the animation of the leaves
and the branches on these palm trees
are simulated by a material function
that is called simple wind
and connected to the world position offset pin
of their materials.
Now the world position offset lets us use our materials
to move or deform parts of our 3D models,
like in this case, these trees,
by changing where their vertices appear in the world.
So we can make grass sway, flags wave, object wobble,
or a variety of other effects really.
Now, if we click on the first tree,
we can see in the details
that it has two different materials assigned to it.
We have the leaves material, which is animated,
and then we have a different material for the trunk,
which is stiff.
Now, if we hit on the palm tree,
we can see that it was set up differently.
In fact, it has only one material,
but the branches are moving a little bit
and the trunk isn't.
This was achieved by using a vertex painting technique
to mask out the trunk manually.
If we switch from selection mode to mesh paint,
we get access to a few options to assign different colors
or ways to our vertices.
And down here, if we change the color view mode
from off to RGB channels or alpha,
we can really see that these palm trees branches
were hand painted to have full weight on their vertices
and that's why they're moving.
Since this learning path focuses on materials,
in this class, unfortunately,
we won't be focusing on mesh painting,
but only on the creation
of the two-sided foliage materials.
But you can learn more about vertex painting
in the landscape course,
which is available on our learning platform.
Okay, now let's go on
and start creating our foliage material.
So I'm gonna right-click in the content browser
and then create a new material
that I'm gonna be calling M underscore simple three.
And then I'm gonna double-click on it to open it up.
Okay, let's dock this up here.
And the first one we wanna do
is click in an empty area of the graph
and then switch the shading model
from default lit to two-sided foliage.
Okay, most of this material
will actually be set up through textures,
so let's import them into our graph.
I'll be Control-Spacebar
and then navigate to the Megascans folder,
Atlases, Oak Branches,
and I'm gonna be selecting the Albedo,
the AO, which is the ambient occlusion,
the normal, the opacity, the roughness,
and the translucency maps.
Then I'm gonna drag them here into the graph.
All right, let's just shift these nodes a bit around
and let's start by connecting
the Albedo RGB output to the base color.
And we can already see that the two foliage shaders
react differently to the base colors
compared to the other materials
we've been dealing with so far.
Now, let's take care of the subsurface color.
So let's drag out of the RGB output pin
and then connect it to a blend overlay node.
Now, we checked out this node in the past,
so I'm not gonna give you a thorough explanation on it,
but just so you know,
the blend overlay really just simulates
the overlay blend mode effect
from any image editing software that it's out there.
Okay, now I'm gonna be pressing three on my keyboard
and left click on the graph
to create a constant three vector.
And then I'm gonna color it green.
This is basically the color that is gonna shine through
whenever the light hits our lives.
And I'm gonna connect it to the blend input
of the blend overlay
and then connect the blend overlay results
to the subsurface color.
Now I'm gonna switch the preview mesh
from the sphere to the plane,
get a better view on what I'm doing.
Okay, now let's connect the roughness map
to the roughness
and then the translucency map to the opacity.
Now we want to be able to render out
these green areas outside the lifts,
but in order to do that,
we need a way to enable these opacity mask pin
in order for us to plug our opacity mask into it.
And in order to do that,
we really need to click to an empty area of the graph
and then change the blend mode of our material
from opaque to masked.
This way we'll get access to our opacity mask
and then we'll be able to connect the RGB node
of our texture sample into it.
Okay, now as you can see,
that green empty area is now completely transparent,
but if we rotate the camera around,
the other side of this plane
is completely transparent as well.
And we don't want that
because we want to be able to see both the upper side
and the bottom side of our lifts.
And in order to do that,
we need to enable the two-sided option of our material.
And here we have it.
Now the lifts are being displayed on both sides.
Okay, now let's move on
and connect the normal map to the normal
and then the ambient occlusion to the ambient occlusion.
Okay, now we need to take care of animating our lifts
through the world position offset.
There are just a handful of material functions
that work with the world position offset.
And the one we're gonna be using today is one of them.
So let's right click in an empty area of the graph
and add a simple grass wind material function.
Now, again, since this is a material function,
you can easily double click on it and open it up
if you wanna learn how this was originally developed,
but make sure that you don't apply any changes
to this engine material function.
Now, if we want to expose the parameters,
all these four settings,
so I'm just gonna go on and right click on the first one
promote to parameter, second one, and so on and so forth.
Let's promote all of them to parameters.
Okay, now I'm gonna be setting the wind intensity
to something small, like 0.3, the wind weight to 0.2
and the wind speed to 0.5.
Now the additional WPO allows us
to add additional offset to our lifts.
Because if you remember,
the RGB values of a constant tree vector
can be translated to the X, Y, and Z position values
of the vertices of our tree mesh.
Now let's connect the simple grass wind result
to the world position offset.
And we should start seeing the lifts moving,
but they're actually completely still.
Why is that?
So you can see up here
that we have these yellow button enabled.
This just really means that real time
is disabled on our viewport.
So if we click on it,
we will enable real time on a viewport.
And now you can see that our lifts are correctly moving.
So as you can see, this simple grass wind function
basically adds a very general move to our foliage.
Now when instancing our material,
we'll get all these parameters exposed
and we'll really be able to customize
the intensity of our wind.
We'll be able to turn it from this soft breeze
into a storm if we want to.
So let's go ahead and test this out.
I'm just gonna hit save to apply my changes.
And then I'm gonna go to my math.
Let's right click on our simple tree material
in the content browser
and then make an instance out of it.
Remember that the naming conventions
for material instances is MI underscore
name of your material instance.
And then I'm gonna control shift S to save all my changes.
Now we have this preview mesh here at our disposal.
So I'm just gonna drag the material instance
into the head of the tree
and it's going to be applied automatically.
So now, first of all,
I really just wanna show you
the subsurface scattering on this tree
and how the leaves are tinted into this bright green color
that we chose before in our blend overlay node.
The one over here.
And it's really adding a lot of realism to our foliage.
Okay, now let's play around a little bit
with our material instance parameters.
So I'm gonna be opening my material instance
and undock it.
And here, if I expose the wind intensity, speed, and weight
and then increase the wind intensity,
you can see that it will start deforming my tree a lot.
So I'm gonna reduce it down to 0.2.
Then I'm gonna increase the wind speed
to make it look as if the wind was a little stronger today.
Weight is a bit too much, so I'm gonna set it to three.
And you can replay around with all these values
and have fun.
So that was it for our material
and we can switch back to our slides now.
All right, you can find additional documentation
at this link if you're interested
in further expanding your knowledge in material properties.
Thanks for sticking around and in the next course
we'll be developing a dissolve effect transition
using an advanced material function.
I'll see you there.
Bye.